Как понять кому доверять в жизни а кому
не доверять это просто критически важный
вопрос для каждого из нас почему важно
вам уметь доверять и понимать как
доверять потому что без доверия
Невозможно работать в команде без
доверия невозможно продвигаться по
социальной лестнице а весь ваш Успех -
это не что иное как продвижение по
социальной лестнице поэтому умение
доверять и понимать кому доверять - это
критически важный навык без которого
большие успехи и большие достижения
невозможны в принципе К чему приводит
незнание этих правил или ключевых
принципов это приводит к тому что вы
будете терять огромное количество денег
и вы будете терять годы своей жизни
потому что по пути по мере продвижения
вашего к вашему успеху вас будут
подводить вас будут кидать вас будут
обманывать Если вы не усвоить это знание
то вы Вы вынуждены будете повторять Эти
ошибки и таким образом вы всё время
будете крутиться как белка в колесе и не
сможете пробить стеклянный потолок и
добиться больших Поистине больших
достижений умение и знани того кому
доверять и как доверять очень сильно
отличает кардинально отличает богатых
людей от всех остальных Ставьте лайк
этому видео И слушайте внимательно
дальше Я всегда умел создавать большие
компании и работать в команде всегда
сплачивало вокруг себя людей а всегда
создавал команды всегда использовал силу
команды Я практически в бизнесе даже не
помню случая когда я был бы волком
одиночки и работал один это очень сильно
Мне помогало в достижении успеха и
продвижени вперёд но в то же время это
являлось основным Э я бы сказал тормозом
который меня тормозил в моём развитии
или наоборот даже откидывать меня на
несколько лет назад и я потерял на этом
огромное количество денег умение в
команде работать в команде - это
основной навык для достижения большого
успеха Когда вы работаете в большой
команде Вы вынуждены доверять иначе
Работа в команде невозможна Давайте
поймём такую вещь
что поставим знак равенства Работа в
команде - это умение доверять не умеете
доверять не сможете работать с командой
но здесь есть один большой подвох подвох
заключается в том что если
кому доверять и как доверять то команда
из мощного инструмента который помогает
вам расти может превратиться в мощный
инструмент отбрасывания вас Назад причём
назад на несколько лет назад и назад на
несколько миллионов долларов назад я на
этом потерял огромное количество денег
если не сказать миллиарды А я уверен у
каждого из вас есть целый сундук таких
историй просто вспомните свои истории
Как вас кидали Как вас обманывали Как
вас обворовывать и так далее и почему
это происходило в основном Основной
причиной являлось то что вы доверяли и
доверяли неправильно Опишите свою
историю в комментариях будет интересно
почитать Я думаю не только мне но и всем
тем людям которые посмотрят это видео
для того чтобы все люди по извлекли
пользу не только из моего видео но и
также из ваших комментариев и из ваших
историй умение Доверять как я уже сказал
является ключевым фактором успеха работы
в команде но Давайте разберёмся Что
такое доверие Доверие само по себе
происходит от слова верить то есть
верить доверять - это значит кому-то
верить А в чём смысл Веры заключается
смысл Веры заключается в том что смысл
веры в кого-то
подразумевает предсказуемость поведения
этого человека так вот Доверие вызывает
предсказуемость поведения того человека
которому мы доверяем недаром в народе
Говорят если человек ведёт себя
непредсказуемо про такого человека
Говорят он неадекватен неадекватный
человек никогда не вызывает ни у кого
Доверие потому что вы не знаете что от
него ожидать так вот Доверие возникает
когда человек оправдывает ожидание То
есть он его поведение соответствует тому
поведению которое вы от него ожидаете и
вот для того чтобы эффективно работать в
команде все члены команды должны быть
адекватны и
действовать в соответствии с ожиданиями
и это порождает Доверие но как я сказал
здесь очень много подводных камней
проблема прежде всего в том что само
Доверие у нас будем говорить так
переоценен Вот я например вспоминая свои
случаи я всю жизнь помню я всё время
уточнял своё вот это а убеждение у меня
Я вырос на убеждении что доверяй И не
Проверяй это убеждение которое мне было
забито ещё са самого детства ещё с
советских времён и оно считалось Так что
доверяй И не Проверяй потому что своей
проверкой ты оскорбляешь человека
которому ты доверяешь Но на основе этого
убеждения меня кинуло моя команда А я
потерял компанию и остался с 12 млн
долларов Долгов практически без ничего
это убеждение меня очень сильно подвело
и тогда я подумал Где ошибка Где ошибка
И когда я анализировал где ошибка я
понял что ошибка была в моём убеждении
доверяй И не Проверяй После этого я
решил заново делать бизнес начал делать
бизнес и я изменил своё убеждение и моё
новое убеждение звучало так доверяй И не
Проверяй Но знай кому доверять и на этом
убеждении я создал ещё несколько
компаний опять начал развиваться вылез
долгов и так далее и так далее Всё вроде
хорошо шло и меня опять подвели моя
команда меня обмануло и я опять попал в
ту же самую яму И тогда я понял что моё
убеждение доверяя и не проверяя Просто
зная кому доверять является ошибочным
почему он оказалась ошибочным потому что
я понял что я не разбираюсь в людях Я не
разбираюсь в людях и поэтому это
убеждение не работает я изменил вновь
изменил изменил своё а убеждение я начал
так как два раза сильно обжёгся я
изменил формулу на доверяй И Проверяй Я
заметил такую вещь что Наф на Формуле
доверяй И Проверяй у меня не удавалось
хорошо и быстро создавать компании
Потому что когда я ставил
проверяющих то это порождало недоверие в
целом в команде и вся команда работала
неэффективно и очень скоро я убедился
что эта формула не работает потому что
проверяющих самих нужно проверять то
есть формула доверяй И проверяй не
работает потому что проверяющих тоже
надо проверять И это бесконечный процесс
это как погоня собаки за своим хвостом
на этой формуле я э заметил что я не
могу добиваться больших успехов поэтому
я поменял своё убеждение и И после этого
она у меня звучала так Проверяй потом
доверяй То есть если раньше было доверяй
И не Проверяй потом доверяй И Проверяй а
потом Я перешёл
Проверяй а потом доверяй то есть
проверку я вынес перед тем как доверять
и на этой формуле я поработал неплохо
начал создавать вновь компании но
заметил такую вещь что эта формула не
очень работает она не очень быстро
работает потому что на проверку
требуется время и очень сложен сам
процесс проверки отбора правильных
кандидатов таким образом По ходу жизни я
поменял эту формулу На следующее
проверяй потом
доверяй И не создавай условий при
которых он может не оправдать твоих
ожиданий вот сегодня я работаю по этой
формуле Как это работает в жизни Вот
когда я беру например на работу человека
Я обязательно говорю что я во-первых
настроен работать с
тобой всю жизнь то есть обязательно
декларируется людям что вы настроены с
ним сотрудничать всю жизнь неважно это
сотрудник или ваш Агент поставщик или
подрядчик или реализатор ваш и так далее
сразу декларирует
человеку своё намерение работать с ним
на протяжении всей жизни это сразу же
поменяет фокус того человека и он с с
близорукой позиции перейдёт в
дальнозоркость он начнёт уже оценивать
ваши отношения совсем по-другому его
отношение к труду отношение к вам
изменится Это первый момент Но я ставлю
условие
Я хочу работать с тобой всю жизнь но у
меня есть небольшое условие я должен
убедиться что ты того стоишь поэтому я
обычно
прошу испытательный срок не 2 месяца А
до года то есть я говорю смотри если я
окончательно убежу что ты тот человек
тогда я хочу работать с тобой всю жизнь
но для этого мне давай поработаем если
это не сотрудник А например подрядчик Я
говорю давайте поработаем пробно сначала
Если всё О'кей дальше пробно таким
образом я пробую пробую человека для
того чтобы убедиться что он умеет
правильно решать проблемы Он справляется
с заданием А и его компетенция
соответствует тому О чём он заявил то
есть Таким образом у меня формула сейчас
такая Проверяй Проверяй
Проверяй потом доверяй И не создавай
условий чтобы он обманул твои ожидания
что не создавать условий Это значит что
я
выстраивают действовать добросовестно
нежели
недобросовестно это раз а во-вторых Я
создаю такую культуру в компании при
которым недобросовестные люди сразу же
вылетают это достигается за счёт метрик
И за счёт культуры компаний Я когда
размышлял вообще над этой
формулой
и Коррупция в принципе имеет такие же
корни и я вот формулу
обрисовал и объединил и понял что они
имеют одну природу Вот например в чём
истоки коррупции Откуда она происходит А
ведь когда Люди обманывают меня в
компании или воруют это по сути то же
самое коррупция только не в
государственных органах А в частных Я
понял что формула коррупции она звучит
так что алчность
плюс
возможность минус контроль и я тогда
понял чтобы меня не обманывали нужно
делать так чтобы не брать алчных людей
первое То есть первый основной упор на
правильный выбор людей с правильными
ценностями для которых обманывать или
брать взятки или воровать вообще чуждо
таким образом вы уже можете предсказать
поведение этого человека Вы знаете что
он не может не сможет своровать
Не потому что какие-то условия а потому
что это его ценности он никогда не
пойдёт против себя его контролёр сидит
внутри него вопрос того какой это
человек я обычно определяю на
собеседовании это раз а во-вторых ну я
Не говоря уже про рекомендации
собеседование рекомендации но и Вот этот
более длительный срок проверки благодаря
проверке я сразу же вижу это видно везде
то есть потому как он назначает цену
потому как он выполняет работу потому
как он ставит приоритеты что для него
важнее качественно удовлетворить запрос
клиента или себестоимость и так далее и
так далее То есть по вот этим всем
вопросам видно что человек на что
способен на что не способен поэтому
первое нужно исключить чтобы к Вам
попадали люди которые Вас могут обмануть
второе
это поставить их в такую ситуацию или
среду при которых у него нет возможности
нет возможности своровать и нет
возможности обмануть ваши ожидания То
есть как это я уже сказал Это метрики
это культура
это Стимул и мотивация действовать
добросовестно И третье
контроль я обязательно у меня построен
сквозной контроль везде при котором
контролирую не я а
контролируют другие люди Вот есть такой
принцип
вда
компания делится на подразделение и одно
подразделение продаёт свои услуги
следующему подразделению таким образом
контролирую качество не я а следующее
подразделение является покупателем по по
отношению к предыдущему то есть
разделение компании на внутренних
продавцов и покупателей Ну это больше
такое бизнес наверно термин Да но Вы
всегда должны выстраивать контроль таким
образом чтобы вы контролировали не вы А
контролировали другие образом если
говорить про то кому умение кому
доверять и как доверять
а формула звучит так что набирайте
только тех людей которые не могут вас
обмануть Это можно выявить за счёт
собеседования проверки и рекомендации и
так далее причём проверки Я имею в виду
испытательного срока а совместного
делания какого-то проекта и так далее не
создавайте возможности чтобы вас смогли
обмануть И третье делайте контроль таким
образом чтобы контроль зависел не от вас
потому что вы занятой человек или даже
не занятой Если ваше внимание всё время
кто-то отвлекает и Вы являетесь узким
горошком в контроле нужно выстраивать
процессы так чтобы вы не контролировали
или
контролировали только ключевые точки А
подскажите как быть тем начинающим
предпринимателем главный девиз которых
хочешь чтобы было сделано хорошо сделать
своими руками они живут с этим девизом
что вы можете им сказать как можете
помочь выйти за этого есть большое
количество предпринимателей которые
думают или которые имеют убеждение что
если хочешь что-то сделать хорошо Делай
сам я Вам сразу скажу это глубоко
ошибочное заблуждение это заблуждение
показывающее только одно то что вы не
умеете доверять раз и во-вторых то что
вы не встречали людей круче вас дело в
том чтобы расти кратно И иметь хорошие
показатели и в бизнесе в прибыли в
личной жизни и так далее Вы всегда
должны себя окружать людьми которые
круче вас по всем параметрам таким
образом вы поймёте что вы сами многого
добиться не сможете это раз во-вторых а
не факт что делая что-то Сами вы
сделаете лучше лучше специалиста в
какой-то сфере вы сделать не сможете
Никогда Когда вы используете это
убеждение что хочешь сделать что-то
хорошо Делай сам то вы сами себя делаете
горшком своего развития вы никогда не
сможете сделать бухгалтерский учёт лучше
чем бухгалтер вы никогда не сможете
сделать маркетинг лучше чем маркетолог
чем логист чем продажник и так далее Всё
искусство заключается в том чтобы не
заниматься специализацией а уметь
организовать вокруг себя специалистов
которые каждый из них круче в своём деле
А это возможно при условии что вы можете
правильно доверять и знать кому кому как
доверять чаще всего это говорят например
какой-то известный Портной который шьёт
замечательно костюмы на пошив он
занимается этим 30 лет и больше и
реально не может никого найти лучше себя
в этом деле и он как вот застыл в этом
это нормально и пускай остаётся так либо
всё-таки ему стоит там активнее искать
людей команду те люди которые сами
занимаются ручным трудом Или сами
непосредственно производит какую-то
ценность и когда они говорят что хочешь
сделать что-то хорошо делай
это отчасти правильно но только отчасти
потому что у любого дела Вот возьмём
даже Портнова который шьёт костюм у
любого дела обязательно 80% операции они
стандартные и рутинные и 20% - это
творчество это нужна интуиция намёт глаз
и так далее и так далее поэтому берёте
любое дело пошив костюма если его
разбить на операции то выяснится что
очень много рутинных операций которые
можно спокойно делегировать другим людям
всё искусство заключается в том что вот
богатые люди или успешные люди Они
концентрируются фокусируются на ключевых
точках и занимаются ключевыми делами всё
остальное они делегируют А те люди
которые не умеют делегировать не умеют
доверять они пытаются делать всё в том
числе и рутинные операции поэтому это
неэффективный
путь расти и достигать каких-либо
успехов это мы всё в вопросах для
предпринимателей а для обычных людей вот
в целом как понять В какой автосервис
отдать доведить свой автомобиль какой
няне доверить воспитание детей Как
доверять вот в бытовых вопросах людям
вот в сфере услуг или чего-то ещё где мы
Ну вот можем устроить там кучу
собеседований всего а Доверие такое
большое и серьёзное требуется Ну это
всегда как я говорил по моей формуле для
того чтобы вам выбрать любой там хороший
автосервис хорошую прачечную хорошую и
или ещё что-то А прежде всего надо
посмотреть
базовые данные стартовые это может быть
резюме в случае если вы выбираете
человека если это автосервис то смотрите
их прайслист или
сайт описание какие услуги они оказывают
и так далее Это проехать посмотреть Надо
дальше это обязательно нужно изначально
подходить я называю это презумпция
доверия изначально км относиться как
Хорошим людям и говорит всячески
декларирует что вы настроены работать с
этим автосервисом или
прачечной максимум долга смотрите здесь
это в этом ещё есть такой
психологический трюк Дело в том что все
эти автосервисы мастерки и так далее Кто
бы ни был
они постоянных Долгих клиентов кидают в
последнюю очеред Если прямо им их прям
прижмёт А как правило все кидают
одноразовых клиентов не ценных клиентов
как только вы декларирует что вы хотите
по жизни работать с ними вы сразу
переходите в их мозгу вы перепони ете
себя как ценный клиент хотя вы ещё не
сделали большое количество покупок у них
Но в их глазах вы уже ценный клиент вы
уже многоразовый клиент Что происходит в
бизнесе обычно скидки дают Постоянным
клиентам какие-то специальные условия
дают Постоянным клиентам то есть
Постоянным клиентам всё время какие-то
дают поблажки и Постоянным клиентам дают
наиболее качественную продукцию и
постоянны клиентам уделяется больше
внимания и постоянных клиентов кидают в
самую последнюю очередь если даже Это
оказался негодяй то есть делать образ
будущего постоянного клиента намерение
надо высказать намерение что я хочу с
тобой работать по жизни Вот что ты
можешь и так далее но мне конечно надо
сча вери что ты это можешь делать
качественно после того как ты так
говоришь намерение о том что ты хочешь
работать всю жизнь И как бы ему говоришь
Докажи что ты можешь делать это
качественно его отношение сразу же
меняется Это парадоксально Но вот само
намерение сразу же устраняет Я бы так
сказал 50% причин вас кинуть обмануть
или не оправдать ваши ожидания конечно
же я понимаю что очень сложно с одного
ролика
понять кому как доверять и это вообще
очень большая обширная тема поэтому
подпишитесь на мой Telegram канал где я
больше освещаю этих вопросов и вообще
погрузитесь в эту среду среду
эффективности общения и вы поймёте очень
много вещей которые будут полезны в
вашей жизни ссылку на Telegram я оставлю
внизу